[Music]
many people need more help today than
ever before but asking for assistance
has never been harder even in the best
of times reacha research shows we
underestimate the chances someone will
support us when we ask them to by nearly
50 percent social psychologist heidi
grant is the author of the book
reinforcements how to get people to help
you she's here to share some tips on how
to ask for help when you need it so we
all know that asking for help under
normal circumstances is difficult but
you say now it's even harder than ever i
think so because a couple of things i
mean we're all struggling i think for
the last couple of years so there's
there's more of a need for help than
ever before but people are still
reluctant to actually admit that they're
struggling right we're always a little
bit afraid of being judged negatively
and then also we're i think more than
ever afraid to be a burden to other
people realizing you know the people
around us are struggling too but if you
say you say if you have to do it number
one heidi has this great ted talk which
is
chock full of information because i'm
doing all the things wrong
if you have to ask for help you have to
do it in person either face to face
don't send an email don't send a text
which i think is very difficult i know
and and it's because you know we are
more comfortable asking for help when we
do it via email or text right because
you know we're kind of not on the spot
but the other side of it is they're not
on the spot either right so it's very
easy to ignore an email or ignore a text
or kind of come up with an excuse we're
actually about 30 times more likely to
get a yes when we ask for help if you do
it's live right it can be a phone call
it can be virtual isn't that because you
put the person on the spot pressure
that's what i think right
a little a little bit on the spot a
little bit but it's also in part that
you're able to kind of make your case
for the need for help but it's more
clear to me that you need help when
you're when we're able to talk through
it and the other piece that's really
important to remember because we are
afraid of being a burden to other people
is that giving someone help is actually
one of the most reliable sources of
self-esteem and well-being that human
beings have we're really wired to feel
psychologists call it the warm glow of
helping
so so when we have that in that actual
live interpersonal interaction i'm
thinking about how good it's going to
feel to help you and and that actually
motivates me to say yes and you're
saying don't apologize oh no very
specific no actually don't make it
with you right right i'm so sorry i'm
sorry i never do this yes yeah i don't
usually do this
it's the worst it's the worst
you rob people how am i supposed to feel
good about helping you when you feel so
terrible about asking for help so you
make it weird like you kind of take the
joy out of the moment for me as a helper
so don't apologize there's never
anything to apologize for and this way
you're actually allowing that other
person to get the maximum benefit from
helping no heidi i like you said be
specific don't because i always hate
when people do gail i just really want
to catch up how about lunch and i say
february 32nd
because you know what's coming exactly
they want something nobody ever just
nobody ever just wants to catch up with
me right so you're saying avoid that
generic ketchup oh absolutely because it
makes people uncomfortable part of why
we're uncomfortable is you're going to
ask me for help i know you are and i
don't maybe and maybe i don't i'm not
able to give it i'd rather know ahead of
time i'd like to you know talk about x
and that way i know if i can't help you
maybe i can put you in touch with
somebody okay what about the burden that
you do feel let's talk about how an
individual feels when you do go hat in
hand right probably the wrong language
that's how i feel right you're going in
hey
you know because i don't like to i don't
like people to feel as if i'm reliant on
them so i'm kind of an independent yeah
yeah and and i was too it's actually why
i wrote the book i was trying to help
myself be better about asking for help
because i was terrible at it i think we
need to actually reframe the whole thing
in our minds
asking for help is a win-win right again
if i ask you for help i'm creating a
situation where you get to feel amazing
honestly there's very few things that
make us feel this good sure and i get
the help i need but we have to remember
it's also ideally mutual right so we're
helping each other we're all getting the
help we need it's actually one of the
few win-wins that are out there because
it can be a reciprocal thing and and
it's important to actually create that
good feeling because then you can return
to people again and again for support
which tends to be what we need all right
so let me use some of your tips yeah
will you come back at some point
okay thank you all right the ted talk
was very helpful i'll be right back
good job thanks guys
[Applause]
hat in hand that's how i feel like